Health care industry is huge, and
there are a lot of data
coming out of health care.
U.S. health care is
incredibly expensive.
Overall spending is $3.8
trillion in U.S. per year.
That's more than the value of
ten biggest companies plus ten
Beijing Olympics plus a Warren Buffet,
and a Bill Gates.
But does it have to be that way?
There is massive waste in
health care unfortunately.
The estimated waste in U.S.
healthcare alone is $765 billion.
That's equivalent to the NASA's
total budget for the past 50 years.
Not only the cost is an issue, but
also the quality of healthcare is poor.
There are 200 to 400 thousand
preventable deaths per year in the U.S.
That's 1,000 people per day.
Four preventable deaths
occurred during this video.
If we classify the preventable deaths
against other causes of deaths,
it will be the number three causes
of deaths in the United States.
After only heart disease and cancer.
So, there are massive problems
presented in modern health care.
Including high costs,
high waste, and low quality.
How can big data help?
The hope is big data can lead
to better care and lower cost.